hi my name is lily mcnellis i'm the head
of outbound product management and
strategy for vertex ai at google cloud
thank you for joining us at next
today we're going to talk about how
vertex ai is now even easier for
developers and how these advancements
help enterprises to deploy more models
gain valuable business insights and
fully realize the value of their ml
investments
i'm thrilled that later in today's
session i'll be joined by matt ferrari
of wayfair and jaime espinosa of twitter
to discuss how each of their
organizations have embraced vertex ai to
solve significant challenges and evolve
their machine learning strategies
first let's set the scene for the
reality that most organizations are
facing today with ai customers tell us
and analysts confirm that almost half of
ml models built never make it into
production
when organizations aren't able to deploy
their models their hard working teams
have built they can't realize the full
value of their ai investments this
results in low roi and a lack of
willingness to continue investing in ai
strategies from senior leadership
this leads to missed opportunities to
actually use insights from ai to inform
business decision and waste high value
talent that can actually lead to
retention issues in this very
competitive job market
so what can organizations do to increase
the number of models in deployment and
actually see a return on their ai
investments
according to mckinsey's 2020 the state
of ai report ai high performers those
seeing meaningful return have
standardized machine learning platforms
for all stages of data science data
engineering and machine learning
workflows
organizations who adopt end-to-end
in-house ai platforms are more likely to
be successful in their implementation of
machine learning to ease deployment and
to realize the value of their
investments more quickly
so how is google helping customers
navigate ai transformations and avoid
common pitfalls
google's commitment to our customers
success means that we
are investing in three focus areas to
ease ml deployment in the enterprise
first platform centralization and
unification
bringing together the best of google's
ai development and deployment tools into
a single unified workflow for our
customers
second accelerating time to value our ml
ops tooling allows you to monitor and
adjust your deployed models faster and
with better insights additionally we're
bringing to market a suite of ai
solutions built to address the most
common use cases
and lastly trust and responsibility
we're continuing to lead in responsible
ai and building tools to empower our
customers to do the same
so let's dig into platform
centralization and unification a little
bit
google cloud offers a unified ecosystem
of data and ai capabilities designed to
make it easy for everyone to innovate
we connect the different types of data
processing from planet scale oltp
systems to analytics
to data lakes to data science to
business analytics we connect the
different roles that work with data and
provide them a common platform to build
upon
we enable an ecosystem of external data
partner and open source systems
and finally we bring all this together
with vertex ai a standardized end-to-end
workflow to allow customers to truly
realize the value of their data through
ai
you may remember that at google i o this
year less than five months ago we
announced vertex ai which is a unified
ai platform
vertex ai creates the connections in the
data science workflow from a technical
standpoint to fast track the path to ml
innovation through collaboration
automation of mundane or redundant tasks
and by integrating deployment and
management tools to streamline mlx
the very premise of vertex ai was to
unify google's ml toolset and to make
experimentation process faster
accelerate deployment and to simplify
model management with our mlaps features
we've seen real traction and customer
adoption of vertex ai in comparison to
previous versions of our ai platforms
available for over five years we have
seen the following areas of growth
between vertex ai's general availability
being announced in may 2021 and august
2021.
the total volume of apis on our platform
has tripled the volume of vertex ai
training has increased by one and a half
times and the volume of predictions on
our entire platform has doubled since
vertex ai was announced in mid this also
has seen we've also seen a 2x increase
in gpu hours for predictions we have
delivered on our promise to serve more
productions and deploy more models with
vertex ai
we know enterprises are often concerned
that increasingly centralized workflows
could come at the cost of governance and
compliance issues
google addresses this by building vertex
ai with security and compliance features
built in
many of those features highlighted in
green that you see on the slide or in
preview in may and we're excited to
share with you that they will be
reaching general availability within the
coming weeks we wanted to highlight a
few of these for you today
vertex ai metadata tracks the inputs and
outputs of an ml pipeline as well as a
lineage of artifacts which can play a
critical role in debugging and
compliance
once your model is in production vertex
ai model monitoring alerts your data
scientists to data drift or items which
may need their supervision this enhances
the compliance and audibility of models
vertex ai pipelines are reusable
pipelines that help data scientists
share components and iterate quickly
vertex pipelines are built with a
python sdk so you can author both kfp
and tfx pipelines with ease
our pipeline service is completely
serverless allowing you to scale up or
down as you need it as you need to
without having to worry about managing
infrastructure
ml engineers are already using vertex ai
pipelines to move faster from prototype
to production and to further accelerate
time to value
for more advanced workloads enterprises
can now use vertex ai neural
architecture search to optimize neural
networks and they can use our vertex ai
matching engine service which gives the
ability to quickly and efficiently look
up nearest neighbor embeddings for
recommendations in search need without
the need for human intervention
data science is a transformational
investment for many customers and and
has continued to evolve as ai and data
have become even more tightly integrated
in the enterprise customers want
seamless experiences across business
units and want a unified data and ml
experience so today we're pleased to
announce a public preview of our vertex
ai workbench
a natural evolution of google's notebook
offerings to respond to the
ever-changing needs of our customers
vertex ai workbench is a single
environment for data scientists to
complete all of their ml work from
experimentation to deployment to
managing and monitoring models
it is a jupiter-based fully managed
scalable enterprise ready compute
infrastructure with easily enforceable
policies and user management
with vertex ai workbench data analysts
data scientists and all data ai
practitioners can analyze all of their
data from bigquery dataproc spark looker
and vertex ai all in one interface
vertex ai workbench facilitates
data to training at scale with fewer
lines of code and easy connectivity to
our mlot services to improve model
survivability at the critical handoff
point to ml engineers
using vertex ai workbench you can
implement your continuous integrated
integration training and deployment
workflows
additionally through our partnership
with nvidia developers will have the
ability to deploy vertex ai workbench
notebooks from nvidia ngc with a single
click nvidia's ngc is a hub for gpu
optimized ai software including
frameworks models sgk
sdks and jupyter notebooks a number of
our customers are already using vertex
ai workbench to ease ml deployment and
support their company's transformations
so we're thrilled to include two of
these customers to share their stories
with us today
twitter and wayfair
matt and jaime please could you
introduce yourselves and share more
about your organizations and your ml
strategies
sure well thank you lilly my name is
matt ferrari i lead our martech and data
and ml platforms organizations both on
the product and the engineering side
in terms of wayfarer we're one of the
world's largest home retailers we serve
just over 31 million active customers
and we have over 22 million products
but often from the outside we're seeing
as a retailer or a home goods company
the truth is
we're much more we have a very robust
platform one that scales across many
countries and is really steeped in big
data ml micro services and many other
technologies that we're going to talk
about today all in the spirit of
bringing world-class service to our
customers
awesome and jaime can you share a little
about yourself
thank you um uh twitter i'm the lead pm
for productizing ml my team is called
cortex it's tasked with accelerating
the
development of machine learning across
all of twitter
we do this through research applied ml
and we provide an end-to-end platform on
which all of the ml of the company is
created from ideation all the way into
productization
great
matt could you tell us a little bit more
about your cloud journey and the
partnership with google cloud and what
were the key decision factors that you
contemplated when making the decision to
partner with google's cloud
sure
wayfair started down the path with gcp a
few years ago
was an early adopter across multiple gcp
services ranging from kubernetes to
bigquery to data proc and we were
already partners with google for our
advertising business but what we really
looked at when we thought about gcp was
an ai
driven organization that's also a major
player in the open source community and
a thought leader in the ml space and so
we saw
google as a true technology partner and
specifically we're driven to their
openness to provide feedback in helping
influence gcp's roadmap
beyond ai the underlying products such
as bigquery dataproc and now vertex ai
are examples of that and it's just kind
of the the beginning of wayfair diving
into things like data velocity quality
and data engineering as it applies to
machine learning
awesome
and jaime could you please tell us more
about your transformational priorities
for machine learning at twitter and how
gcp is helping you reach those
transformational goals
um across twitter there are many teams
that are working together
and because of the complexity and the
scale at which we're operating there are
many opportunities to leverage machine
learning
uh our ml platform powers every stage of
the ml project from experimentation uh
all the way into productization in the
maintenance right at the mlaps
it is ultimately a hybrid system it's uh
only able to be built because of the
partnership that we have with gcp
amazing and matt what use cases or
business problems were you looking to
solve when you started working with
google cloud and adopting vertex ai
sure
we envisioned a lot of use cases at
wayfair they started in in marketing and
search and recommendations think about
how can we make sure you're you're
searching for the right product and then
recommendations you know moving forward
we thought about product catalog supply
chain and even end-to-end customer
service and we thought look all of that
can benefit from machine learning and in
turn vertex ai in fact even though it's
still early phases of that journey
there's already parts of that ml life
cycle that you know that really sing
that today you know for example
really kind of we we built it on the
principles of how do we make ml at
wayfarer easier
that means you know examples would be
how do we accelerate time to value for
new models by reducing the model
training duration of each development
iteration we also thought about how do
we
reduce friction while we're building and
deploying models at scale while still
increasing reliability and speed
of how do we retrain jobs to make sure
that data scientists can focus on data
science work
and then we really focus on how do we
enable ml in the fabric of how we make
decisions for the business so how do we
intertwine it into our strategic
objectives across wayfarer and our early
results have been really positive the
truth is that we have a lot of very
large model training jobs that are
between 5 and 10 times faster at this
point and we've we've gotten feedback
from our data scientists that they
specifically like all of the hyper
parameter tuning available to them
and on that point what is the mo what is
most important to you and your data
scientists when you focus on deploying
ml models at scale
sure uh so i would tell you that before
it would if i entered in interviewed
them they would say it was really around
data quality and duplication of data or
lack of integrity of data hey matt i
don't trust the data or i have data
sprawl everywhere and what we're really
focused on there is how do we drive time
to value for new models and model
enhancements how do we focus on quality
of predictions that drive business
impact and then finally how do we
automate as much as possible in a
post-deployment model from a monitoring
and tuning perspective
awesome and i'm curious jaime what is
most important to you and your data
scientists when you focus on deploying
ml models at scale at twitter
because twitter has a unique and
incredible impact on the world
maybe because of this fact we are
growing very fast
as twitter grows uh so does the
diversity of the talent that brings in
and so does the diverse speak of thought
the diversity of techniques and tools is
actually very important for us to
maintain in order to
be fair as uh in to learn from each
other
twitter offers also a unique opportunity
to work deeply across multiple ml fields
this also uh
translates into how we represent data
how we
what kinds of system requirements we
have uh we have found that
uh flexibility is really the key to
empower our talent um it is uh
i think it's it's
very common for us for anybody that we
are trained with particular type of
tools and techniques and and these are
the ones the things that makes that
we're very familiar with and it is what
makes us the most productive and being
able to
provide this within the email platform
we've found is the best way to
uh enable everybody to
be as product as productive as possible
great and you just mentioned a few but
are there any other key learnings that
you would like to share with other
organizations um that you've come across
as you continue continuing to scale to
the magnitude you're currently operating
at
absolutely um
well first uh give you a sense for for
scale
uh twitter operates at a mind-blowing
scale and a mind-blowing speed uh these
in this are requirements that continue
to grow
uh very steadily
over i'll share a bit uh over my career
i've worked in about uh
in eight platforms uh six of which were
ml platforms this were across info
microsoft algorithmia and now twitter
and out of all this experience i can
honestly say that twitter pushes
the envelope on almost every boundary
uh and um
it is based on on that experience that
uh
which we've seen some some key learnings
and this includes the addition the
increasing importance of the co-design
of the ml models and the infrastructure
both of these need to to have a sort of
balance between them so when we think of
the end-to-end platform it has to strike
a balance that balances out the
infrastructure and technology with the
ml and ultimately the business
so
uh one of the biggest
predictors for success for a project has
been uh how that how well does the
talent understand both the ml and the
infrastructure
and
as for pms additionally we also are
looking to for understanding of the
business and the product the product
design some base product assignment
so um
it is uh some of some of these things
that we're trying to address or or
simplify with our ml platform in which
we abstract out some other
infrastructure we make it easier through
tools we make it flexible and uh so that
we can
better focus on the ml the building of
these models
awesome that makes a ton of sense and i
think that's exactly how we hope folks
are thinking about the advantages that
vertex ai can bring to their
organizations
matt can you share a little bit more
about how vertex ai helped with your
needs and how easy it was to get started
sure
uh so so far to baseline we've adopted
vertex ai workbench and ai training
components across the vertex platform
both of those components have
accelerated our adoption
of highly scalable model development and
training capabilities with a real focus
on you know are they purpose built and
at scale for for weight fair's needs
we've got really enthusia enthusiastic
adoption from our own data science
community you know for example to put
some numbers behind it
we rolled out vertex ai workbench
a few months ago and over a period of 30
days already had more than 100 users on
the platform spanning across 35 projects
and candidates growing constantly um in
terms of ease i would say that we have
an ml platforms organization
specifically built accelerators for our
data scientists to adopt these
components easily such as integrations
into our internal provisioning solutions
along with sample code or automatically
created dags that utilize ai training
platform within existing airflow decks
amazing
we're so excited to hear that you're
already having so much success with
vertex ai workbench and at google we're
thrilled to contribute to the
transformational ml journeys of both
twitter and wayfair thank you both so
much for your time today and for sharing
your insights and thanks to everyone for
watching and tuning in
you